it could seem bizarre quite how long we
spend on those strands of string keratin
sprout unreliably from our scalps we
will over a lifetime throw thousands of
hours and even more money and
hairdressers careful attempts to coax
and sculpt on by fewer into exactly the
right color shape and dimensions there
are days when our entire mood will be
supported by a scent that our hair is
cooperating and others when our spirits
will be just as powerfully ruined by an
unfortunate glimpse of our disobedient
locks in an elevator mirror why does it
matter so much because however odd this
may sound we are using our hair to speak
we're trying through the syntax of
colored protein filaments to express key
aspects about who we are it always
precarious for us to transmit our
identities to those around us we rely on
other accompanying details our shoes our
jewelry our clothes and of course those
centrally those strands of hair
everyone's hair speaks in a slightly
specific dialect but I can with relative
ease to find some of the main entries in
humanity is vast and new asked
dictionary of hair tightly pulled back
we're letting the world know that we're
busy organized and not to be interrupted
lightly long flowing and tangled we're
reminding society that opposition to
some other demands of modern capitalism
with spiritual beings our hair is saying
we have a heart and make the time to
notice what really counts
emphatic side parting we're using hair
to tell others that with careful modest
patient sensible and very willing to be
realistic we can be relied upon Russia
forwards closely propped in the manner
of a Roman general we're too immersed
our hair informed society in the real
battles of life to care about trivia we
make our hair I'd say we've grown
indifferent to criticism and in a good
way with hard to impress her Keeley is a
intricate language the problem will even
tragedy is that other people aren't
necessarily paying very much attention
at - what if we encounter this awkward
reality in the difficult moments after
our return from pensive and slow-moving
address
we rejoin our friends or lovers with an
expectant what you think only then to
recede mind the confused responses and
those trousers do you or have you lost
weight we felt that it mattered so
ardently that the locks are now combed
just a little more to the left and a one
shade closer to blond but others don't
give a damn though in the privacy of
their own bathrooms they too will take
immense care about what their hair is
saying and yet what we're encountering
in the limited context of hair is simply
a problem that haunts us throughout our
lives the essential loneliness of the
human animal we have an extraordinarily
limited power to get others to care
about and understand us the way we serve
phrase to be grasped and vice versa
we shouldn't mock others for caring so
much about their hair or berate
ourselves for doing the same we're just
engaged in a poignant business of
attempting to communicate who we are
with all those dyes curlers tongs and
scissors we're just trying to make
ourselves a little more clearly
understood in a world with painfully
little inclination to care did you know
that the school of life is actually a
place ten places in fact campuses all
over the world from Melbourne to London
Taipei to Istanbul with classes and
books and lots more please click on the
link below to explore more